evènement bien sûr ne sont pas sans
répercussions sur nos propres
préoccupations ainsi peut-être
aurions-nous naguère - été attiré par
cette nouvelle découverte de pétrole en
mer du nord par les compagnies française
total et elf aquitaine
mais dans le secteur britannique andré
giraud de son côté invite les français à
ne pas utiliser leur radiateur
électrique d'appoint aux heures de
pointe et le premier ministre prend bien
évidemment en compte toutes ces données
quand ils changent un peu le langage par
rapport aux désastres évoqué il ya
quinze jours
aujourd'hui devant les sénateurs il a
brossé un tableau disons plutôt
optimiste de la conjoncture économique
en ce qui concerne la situation de notre
économie
je dirais ceci premièrement depuis la
fin 2009 178 la france absorbe et les
conséquences du premier choc pétrolier
c'est à dire le choc pétrolier de 73 74
deuxièmement la france est à l'heure
actuelle en train d'absorber mieux que
nous le pensions le deuxième choc
pétrolier
c'est à dire le choc du mois de juillet
dernier et cela pour deux raisons
essentielles la stabilité de sa monnaie
la productivité de ces entreprises
troisièmement la france est aujourd'hui
mieux armées pour faire face aux charges
futures car je ne me dissimule pas que
nous allons au-devant de chocs futurs et
la politique que nous devons mener est
une politique de vie
gilles ans je devais je dirais une
politique tous azimuts par rapport aux
éventualités qui peuvent brusquement
surgir ce n'est pas facile mais l'outil
c'est à dire la capacité de l'économie
française est à l'heure actuelle une
capacité à laquelle nous pouvons faire
confiance et à 6